your majesty mr. president excellencies
ladies and gentlemen good morning and
welcome welcome to the global
vaccination summit protecting health
saving lives
excellencies we live in a challenging
world and the chaos and confusion around
us is not just limited to the
geopolitical landscape it's touching
every part of our lives and it's
touching the health sector as well we
talked here about vaccinations
confidence and we talked also about
vaccination hesitancy and we're here
today to try and make that confidence
stronger we're all part of the same
struggle to improve our health improve
our lives so I'm sure the Islam I'm
director for Europe and geopolitics at
friends of Europe which is a think tank
based here in Brussels we are 400 people
here from different walks of lives
scientific experts medical experts NGOs
industries civil society Your Majesty we
are honored by your presence here you
are an advocate for the sustainable
development goals and of course under a
president of UNICEF Belgium as well so
thank you very much for being here thank
you to all of you for being here just a
few words before we start the opening
ceremony so we have several languages
this conference is being web streamed so
good morning to everyone outside this
room as well we have English as the
language of the summit but we have
interpretation into German French and
Spanish and the earphones are on your
table very important please join the
conversation on social media and the
hashtag is vaccines work and hashtag
vaccination summit 19 without further
ado I'd like to ask the Commission
President jean-claude Juncker please to
give us his opening words and to set the
tone for this conference please mr.
president
[Applause]
like always I'm agitating between
different languages but English has had
its time now it's watch
modesty your majesty good morning
ministers ladies and gentlemen dear
friends for me it is a great honor and a
great pleasure to be able to welcome you
here to this global vaccination summit
we are acting together to meet a huge
challenge saving human lives we have to
act against a fatalistic approach
because we are all in this fight
together including my commissioner at
Vitas Andrew Curtis he has a very
impressive life story he was born in a
gulag so when you discuss issues such as
human rights he has a great deal to tell
us and his biography is here he knows
how to combat injustice how to combat a
fatal asthma and to be positive in his
thinking I am very happy to be able to
organize this summit in conjunction with
dr. Tejas the director-general of the
World Health Organization I would like
to pay homage to his work and his
commitment to ensure universal health
cover I have said on many occasions and
I will continue to say this as often as
necessary that it is of utmost
importance to ensure that we can combat
the hundreds of thousands of children
dying in the world quite simply because
they do not have access to basic health
services it is unacceptable that in the
21st century our children are dying from
diseases which should no longer exist we
have to put an end to this in tolerable
situation this is an obligation which is
incumbent upon each and every one of us
I come from generation which was able to
benefit
from scientific progress in the 1970s
and 80s and I recall that it was thanks
to a vaccination that we were able to a
get rid of smallpox at more than 40
years ago but today despite the year
huge scientific progress which has been
made vaccinations has not yet enabled us
to eradicate other communicable diseases
let's take a measles in 2012 a political
commitment was made to ensure that in
five out of the six regions of the
whu-oh measles that should be eradicated
by 2020 it's now
2019 and the number of cases of measles
is continuing to increase at world scale
and if you look at the situation in 2018
that there are more than three times as
many cases of measles which were
declared in the first months of 2019 in
Europe the number of measles related
deaths increased six-fold between 2016
and 2018 these cases which affect mostly
unvaccinated members of the population
quite simply because too many Europeans
distrust VAX you know 38% of our fellow
citizens think that they cause at the
diseases against which are they are
meant to protect us and that is why
despite the fact that some people are
dying elsewhere in the world because of
the lack of available vaccines some
people here are risking not only their
lives but those of others by refusing
vaccinations some people are not playing
the game of prevention they prefer to
play quite simply with fire this
skepticism I think has its origins in
the some of the disinformation campaigns
which served to undermine vaccines and
said that it was only pharmaceutical
companies so who wished to promote a
vaccines for
of profit-making and this is a type of
fake news and fake information which the
Commissioner is seeking to combat in its
campaign to get rid of disinformation
and working together with the main
Internet platforms
however this is not the only factor
there is also the increased cost of new
vaccines and the lack of investment in
research and vaccine development has led
to this as well as a lack of manufacture
and supply it is in this alarming
context of that in November of last year
dr. Ted Rose and myself discussed how
urgent it was to draw the attention of
the world to this question and to
organize at this summit or we decided
that we would do this in November of
last year it's now September it takes
some time to put our ideas into practice
prevention and elimination of
transmissible diseases is a huge
challenge which can only be successful
if we all work together so I'm very glad
to see how many different nationalities
are represented how many different
stakeholders from different areas and
sectors and I would like to thank you
very much indeed for the commitment
which you have all displayed since
vaccine preventable diseases and
disproportionately affect children I
would in particular like to underscore
the huge role played by the UN Fund for
children
both for the purposes offered today's
work and work elsewhere I think that
there is little doubt that given the
huge challenge ahead of us no single
country and no single organization can
achieve success alone which is why over
the last few years the European
Commission has stepped up the work which
it does to promote equitable and
accessible at health care for all in
close cooperation with our member states
and other world partners such as the
w-h-o
and the world vaccine Alliance since
2003 the European Commission's as
support to the global vaccine alliance
that has permitted at the vaccination of
a 700 million children and has meant
that we can save lives in some of the
poorest countries in our world the
needed to promote international
cooperation it becomes all the more
pressing when we have to deal with
crisis situations such as that of the
Ebola epidemic in the Democratic
Republic of Congo here I would like to
very much pay tribute to the
coordinating role played by the whu-oh
in dealing with this epidemic this rapid
mobilization of a research and huge
investment which has been made by the
European Union in the development and
the deployment of vaccines has helped to
save lives in the Democratic Republic of
Congo and throughout Central Africa the
EU of financing has already meant that
we have produced more than 1.5 million
doses of the new Ebola vaccine which is
now being stored in the DRC and we have
also promoted work being done in
conjunction with the European Medicines
Agency and our member states we have to
learn lessons for the future and what we
have done in coordinating research and
developing vaccines is the key element
in responding to both new threats as
well as older ones which are now
re-emerging more recently at the g7
summit in Biarritz in august the
European Union made an additional 550
million euro a contribution to the
Global Fund which we have been
supporting since it was set up we have
seen the emergence of new epidemics of
tuberculosis and other diseases which we
hope to be able to eradicate we
hope therefore that we will be able to
see this effort growing so that we can
put an end to these diseases between now
and 2030 the fact that the g7 turned its
attention to the subject has
demonstrated the importance of of how
much we needed to work together to
promote the health and the stability for
the world as a whole I count on you and
your participation and on what is going
to be discussed here today a three
million lives saved every year thanks to
vaccination what we can do more and
first and foremost we have to
re-establish the public's trust in
vaccinations and here we all have a role
to play health professionals as well as
representatives that from the tech
sector the media civil society as well
as politicians that we all have a role
to play and I hope that we can all take
up and shoulder this responsibility
thank you very much indeed for inviting
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed mr. president
you've set the tone for our event our
conference all day long you've talked
about the unacceptable situation at the
moment you've talked about it being
alarming you mentioned this information
you mentioned children and it's now our
pleasure also to have a video message
from Miss Henry at 4:00 she's executive
director of the United Nations
Children's Fund please could we have the
video every minute of every day vaccines
save the lives of at least five children
they are one of the most powerful tools
we have to prevent childhood deaths and
yet 20 million infants one in ten
globally were not fully immunized in
2018 there are many reasons for this gap
including poverty conflict complacency
and skepticism recently skepticism about
vaccines has been amplified by
misinformation in social media in a
digital world where rumors spread
instantly confidence in vaccines can
plummet just as fast but rebuilding
Trust takes time we have seen this in
Ukraine where it took a decade for
vaccination rates to rebound after trust
diminished mistrust and misinformation
must not prevail and they will not if we
act now give health professionals the
knowledge resources and training they
need to provide concerned parents with
accurate information work with
governments to invest in health systems
and respond to disease outbreaks and
partner with local social media
platforms to promote vaccine content
from fact-based scientific sources with
any luck will go viral together we've
made remarkable progress in preventing
childhood diseases let us extend that
legacy far into the future
it's now my pleasure to ask Tata Tetris
from the World Health Organization to
please come and give us his words thank
you thank you thank you master of
ceremony Your Majesty the Queen of
Belgians your excellency president Jang
jean-claude juncker president of the
European Commission
my brother Commissioner Andrew Titus
president Kikwete a excellencies
distinguished guests colleagues and
friends first of all I would like to say
good morning and I would like to thank
my sister Henrietta for joining us
virtually and also for the excellent
speech by President Juncker and I offer
my deep thanks to President Juncker for
his leadership in hosting and
coordinating the summit I could see his
passion when as he said when we first
met to discuss but this summit and he
was so worried because the headline of
our meeting at that time was children
are dying in Europe because of
preventable diseases and that was a
serious issue and thank you for your
leadership mr. president vaccines as you
know are one of the most powerful
innovations in the history of medicine
smallpox is no more thanks to vaccines
polio has been pushed to the brink of
eradication thanks to vaccines once fear
diseases
like diphtheria tetanus measles and
meningitis are now easily prevented
thanks to vaccines and new vaccines are
being developed to protect people
against more diseases the new Ebola
vaccine is playing a critical role in
controlling the spread of the current
outbreak in the Democratic Republic of
the Congo as president Juncker said I
would like to use this opportunity to
thank the EU for its support on this and
the world's first malaria vaccine is now
being piloted in three African countries
new vaccines against tuberculosis are
showing promise and researchers around
the world are continuing to the quest
for a vaccine against HIV vaccines are
also a frontline defense against
antimicrobial resistance in short
vaccination is a cornerstone of public
health when we talk about the right to
health we're talking about the right to
vaccines as I often say there is no
health for all without vaccines for all
but the benefits of vaccines extend well
beyond health they're the foundation for
individuals families communities and
nations to flourish vaccines help to
interrupt the cycle that keeps children
trapped in poverty they enable children
to grow and to learn they mean not only
lives saved but lives lived here is some
great news most children born around the
world today will be vaccinated every
year more than 116 million children are
protected from
reduces in routine vaccination programs
this is a tremendous global achievement
but these hard-fought gains are not
enough they can be easily lost
communities in countries around the
world are waking up to this reality
because of low coverage nationally or in
pockets within countries measles
outbreak are spreading rapidly around
the world the number of reported measles
cases globally doubled last year from
2017 and the number of cases so far this
year is already more than any year since
2006 as you know just last month for
European countries including through
three EU Member States lost their
measles free status this is serious
in some countries vaccine hesitancy
contributes to this outbreaks vaccine
misinformation can be as contagious and
as dangerous as the disease it helps to
spread falsehoods about vaccinations
have spread in developed countries in
Europe the US Canada and others but also
in less developed countries like
Pakistan and the Democratic Republic of
Congo jeopardizing the fight against
polio Ebola and other vaccine
preventable diseases of course we're
working with some social media outlets
the recent announcements by Pinterest
and Facebook that they will direct users
to add to accurate and reliable
information about vaccines is very
welcome and a great start but more needs
to be done and we hope they will
do more but all the vaccine hesitancy is
a serious issue it's not the main reason
children miss out on vaccines it's
because they simply cannot access
vaccines globally over 1 in 10 children
born today do not receive basic vaccines
every year 13 million children miss out
altogether they never received a single
vaccine rose most unvaccinated children
live in countries affected by poverty
conflict migration and fragile health
systems but in all countries of all
income levels it's the poorest and most
disadvantaged children who are most
likely to miss out mass urbanization
displacement conflict natural disasters
and environmental disruption all
exacerbate challenges to immunization
and create the conditions in which
disease spread so how can we make sure
all children receive this life-saving
and life enabling products is the
question first political commitment I
know from my own experience in
government that political commitment
from the highest levels is essential for
making progress in 10 days time ordinate
leaders will gather at the United
Nations General Assembly in New York for
the first level meet for the first
high-level meeting on universal health
coverage this is an unprecedented
opportunity to catalyze political
commitment for health including
immunization the foundation of in versal
health coverage is primary health care
and one of the foundations of primary
health care is vaccination second
innovation there are still many diseases
for which we need new vaccines or better
vaccines and there is lack of investment
as President Juncker said in
vaccines but we also need so we also
need innovation and research into how to
deliver vaccines how to make them fully
accessible and desired and we need new
ways of working together that meet the
needs of people especially in the most
marginalized parts of our countries
these are the people were typically most
at risk of the diseases that vaccines
prevent third partnership expanding
access to vaccines is not a job just for
governments or parents or health workers
or UN agencies but all of us everyone
here has a role to play WH o the EU
UNICEF Gavi and all our other partners
we all have comparative advantages to
bring to the table this kind of
partnership doesn't just happen it takes
careful planning and coordination that's
why we need a vision and strategy for
immunization in the next decade through
which we can align our efforts and
maximize our impact forth
investment vaccines cost money programs
cost money
surveillance costs money research costs
money investments in each element of a
strong immunization programs must be
protected and grown if we're to reach
the goals countries have set for
themselves and the world specifically we
stand on the threshold of a monumental
achievement in public health the
eradication of polio we need sustained
investment for this last mile to
eradicate polio the Global Polio
Eradication Initiative pledging event in
Abu Dhabi UAE in November will be a
critical moment for ensuring we have the
resources we need to make polio history
the replenishment of Gavi
the vaccine Alliance next year is
equally important why - I'd like to use
this opportunity to congratulate Gavi
and my dear friend dr. Seth Berkley for
the well-deserved with our Lasker our
congratulations for almost 20 years the
islands has supported the immunization
of more than 700 million children and
prevented more than 10 million deaths
this is big but we're saying not enough
that's why we're here today so now is
not the moment to step back together we
must ensure gap is fully funded and can
continue its life-saving work at the
same time we must find creative
solutions to support countries who no
longer receive Gavi support but are
failing behind in their immunization
programs we need healthy vaccine markets
that support sustainable affordable and
reliable access to vaccines for all
these are significant challenges but
none of them are insurmountable
political commitment innovation
partnership investment this 4 must be
our priorities thank you once again
president Juncker for your commitment
and leadership I look forward to our
continued collaboration with the EU and
with all our partners and this is the
first edition and we hope to continue
the subsequent editions and hope you
will join us and lead together we can
make sure that no child misses out on
the life saving power of vaccines see
you in the next edition of this global
summit thank you merci beaucoup and
which has a successful day thank you
thank you very much doctor treacherous
all for giving us such a complete
picture of the landscape as you see it
today all the topics we've talked about
partnerships innovation information
funding and political leadership are on
our agenda today in different panels
thank you very much indeed
so now you've heard from the senior-most
policy makers and it's my pleasure now
to introduce to you Yvonne Chaka Chaka
you've heard her and you know her
possibly as the princess of Africa she's
an our South African singer songwriter
performer entrepreneur and a global
health advocate and she's a humanitarian
she's got many awards and she is also a
goodwill ambassador for UNICEF so could
I ask the princess of Africa please to
come and speak to us
[Applause]
thank you to our capable emcee Her
Majesty the president of the EU everyone
here present today I'm a South African I
daresay old protocol observed it is a
pleasure for me to join you this morning
I would like to thank the European
Commission and the World Health
Organization for inviting me here to
speak passionately as a committed
advocate for vaccines ladies and
gentlemen I grew up in Soweto
in Dobson vulturing the architect IRA's
my father died when I was only 11 years
old and my mother had to be a domestic
worker because as a woman she was not
allowed to own a house but that did not
deter us me and my sisters we were made
to believe that education can take you
anywhere we wanted we stood with each
other we knew the importance of
community we were bound together in a in
in the community we live together we
lived in the era of Ubuntu which means I
am because you are we bid appetite
because we were one global coherent
community whether inside or outside
South Africa with the same goal together
we can make it as grassroots we fought
we had great leaders like Nelson Mandela
Oliver Tambo Steve Biko Winnie Mandela
and all other women out there through
this experience ladies and gentlemen I
knew firsthand the incredible value
importance and important of strong
empowered communities we all we all have
the role to play here it is important
that we talk about these things ladies
and gentlemen today the struggle goes on
as we fight for greater social justice
and equity in health education nutrition
clean water and sanitation for all in
and the world at large as a mother of
four boys and a grandmother of two
ladies and gentlemen I'm heartened to
say many of these areas in Africa made
incredible progress and I'd like to
thank all the African leaders here
present from president equator to mr.
Ted Rose as the Minister of Health and
other ministers here present Africa now
is the time this is not the time to push
back and for that I would say the
political will it meant a lot and we
have made great strides in saving lives
through vaccines in Africa thank you for
your leadership
Africa's leaders have demonstrated
strong political will from from trying
to achieve universal child in a
universal child immunization through the
90s to more recent artists about
immunization declaration in 2016 at the
28th African summit the desire to bring
vaccination to all no matter who they
are or where they live it is an
admirable goal from my experience in the
upper tech movement we will only succeed
in this lofty goals if we continue to
build strong vibrant inclusive
communities that are knowledgeable
believe and trust in immunization as we
can ensure every child on the continent
is immunized we must ensure that the
voices of those most affected by the
lack of access of vaccination are heard
and their demands to protect their
children are fulfilled this is an
enormous undertaking ladies and
gentlemen I am and I have been a gap
champion ladies and gentlemen just like
my leader and my father Nelson Mandela
who was the first chairperson of Gavi
Davi has done a lot of work ladies and
gentlemen 760 million children have been
immunized and saved we want to thank
them for
doing that you can imagine that if
vaccination was not what people wanted
or what people trusted because of
misinformation how many children would
have been killed the road to polio
eradication has been long and
challenging yet with our collective
efforts or leave to leave no one behind
we are succeeding that is incredible
despite the success today almost half of
unvaccinated children that is eight
point five million ladies and gentlemen
live in Africa that portion will
increase over the coming decades due to
due to rapid population increase it is
shocking that 1.5 million people are
still dying every year from vaccine
preventable diseases reaching the most
impoverished communities is essential to
meeting the sustainable development
goals and achieve universal health
coverage but it is also how we will make
the greatest impact so while it is cost
while it may cost more and be more
difficult to reach remote marginalised
communities it is there that we have the
biggest need and can achieve the biggest
impact
moreover fragile states and protracted
conflict areas results in displaced
people the destruct was the disruption
of vaccination services makes it much
more harder in remote communities to
access health services conflict areas
increased risk of outbreaks and make
effect effective responses more
difficult I'm very sad to say that
measles remain a major killer of
children in Africa ladies and gentlemen
I've watched with increasing concern
that in the last few years missiles is
returning around the world but the
consequences are greatest for Africa
the tragedy is that while many children
in Europe are unvaccinated because of
parents hesitancy due to the growing
impact of anti vaccination campaigns and
misinformation most children in Africa
are unvaccinated because of legs lack of
access and services we need to do all we
can to combat both these challenges by
ensuring strong financial and political
commitment to get the job done
vaccinations for all must become a
reality ladies and gentlemen not just a
campaign we have to do all we can to
fight the anti vaccine contingent
because it gets before it gets
completely out of control and has an
even more determined the determiner of
impact on Africa's children the world
has changed so drastically ladies and
gentlemen since South Africa achieved
back majority in 1994 today knowledge
and information is accessed virtually
via information superhighway and then
repeated extensively via social media
this has increased idea and the
potential of everyone becoming a
so-called expects at least in their own
eyes today the world has become more
polarized and politicized every son even
science is seriously impacted by
politics facts are constantly challenged
and false information spread via social
media ladies and gentlemen we live in
the area of fake news fake news is a
reality and reinforced by social media
silos in which we communicate talking
only to them to other people is
something that we need to be very
careful of
I'm sure everyone attending this meeting
already believes in the impact of the
importance of vaccinations
so essentially ladies and gentlemen all
of us here are converted so we are
preaching to ourselves I'm preaching to
the converted where are the people that
we need to talk to where are the people
who need information but I'm sure
because there's life streaming those
people are getting this information
today that is very very important but we
need to understand that every parent
wants the best for their children to
keep them safe and to protect them
therefore if parents are not vaccinating
their children it is in the belief that
is the best way for them to protect them
so how do we combat the growing
anti-vaccination movement that spreads
fear and in accurate information to
communities all over the world we no
longer know who to trust who to believe
and where to obtain accurate facts we
live in the world where the truth is
relative and we can all have our own
truth we acknowledge that so many
decisions are made for economic gain for
profit and not necessarily for human
benefit so it is understandable there's
a strong distrust out there in the
private sector ladies and gentlemen we
need to do more to bring prices of
vaccinations down to increase production
and to improve access we must begin to
have meaningful dialogues and provide
real scientific data in the way that
ordinary people can understand believe
and trust in the value of immunization
so that they act responsibility
responsibly and lead the fight to demand
their rights to increase access to
vaccines
we desperately need trust with the
community champions ladies and gentlemen
we need more people with no invested
interest who can believe so that we can
fight misinformation and bring these
life savings vaccines to more of the
world's children rapidly I'm happy to be
the community champion and Weber along
side other other people that believe
that it is important to have
vaccinations this war ladies and
gentlemen we must win let no one deter
us I count on you and your partnership
to provide the leadership in mobilizing
the financial and human resource so
every child everywhere without exception
will be vaccinated stand with me in
making the vision of human immunization
reaching every child everywhere a
reality ladies and gentlemen healthy
children healthy families healthy
communities results in healthy economies
let's do it for the sake of our children
ladies and gentlemen as the princess of
Africa foundation always says there is
no wealth without health and education
our children need us and whilst we are
deliberating and doing this go back home
and ask yourself or say this to yourself
still so many answers I don't know
realize the question is how we grow so I
step out of the ordinary I can feel my
soul efendi I'm on my way
can stop me now you can do the same what
have you done today to make you feel
proud it's never too late to try what
proud what have you done today to make
you feel proud
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed
miss shakashaka that was a very
inspiring speech a very personal speech
and my god what a song thank you so much
thank you so much so ladies and
gentlemen excellencies Your Majesty we
come to the end of the opening session
there is coffee healthy coffee I've been
told outside
so please do avail yourself off
refreshments if I could say this after
after the coffee break please be back at
10:30 we have two panels which will
explore many of the issues that our
policy makers and shocka shocka spoke
about how to increase vaccine confidence
and the magic of science so once again
join me in applauding all the speakers
this more